el poder y el poder asimétrico de
cualquier grupo terrorista
pero es un poder significativo el elda
es en esta versión de 'la jurasani que
viene a suponer una provincia imaginaria
para ellos dentro del estado islámico
que ocuparía afganistán y pakistán
el objetivo de su presencia y la amenaza
que suponen es que no van a permitir
ninguna estabilización de afganistán
ellos se manifiestan y se han
manifestado con estos ataques recientes
en el aeropuerto de kabul como un actor
más a tener en consideración en el
escenario de afganistán y van a venir a
complicar mucho más aún el futuro de
afganistán y el futuro de la seguridad
internacional tengamos en cuenta que el
terrorismo yihadista de al qaeda muy
presente y muy fuerte en afganistán de
por sí
fue lo que motivó en definitiva que
occidente
la alianza atlántica acudiéramos después
de los ataques contra eeuu en 2001 que
pudiéramos
en apoyo de eeuu a la misión en
afganistán que ha durado 20 años después
de 20 años no se ha acabado de la
amenaza de al qaeda ni del terrorismo
llega this está bien desgraciadamente
tenemos que reconocer que hemos
fracasado porque esta amenaza sigue
incrementándose como bien señalaba en
estos en este vídeo previo el presidente
de francia en su visita a irak ahora el
tema le pregunto cuál es la relación de
este grupo con los talibanes y cuántos
combatientes tiene que qué magnitud
tiene este grupo terrorista
la cantidad de militantes dentro de
afganistán es muy difícil de precisar
quizás estaríamos hablando de algo más
de 1000 entre 1.000 y 2.000 efectivos
pero es difícil de precisar no obstante
aunque parece que es una presencia
reciente no lo es en los últimos meses
hemos visto desde el año 15 hay
presencia pero pero en los últimos meses
hemos visto ataques terroristas en las
salas de de
asistencia al parto en escuelas
infantiles e incluso el asesinato de
varios cooperantes que estaban
colaborando en el desminado de
determinadas zonas por lo tanto el dax
en esta versión en afganistán se ha
hecho presente y ha lanzado un mensaje
al mundo muy potente para este mundo
criminal del terrorismo yihadista y es
que fuimos allí afganistán provocados
espoleados por el terrorismo yihadista y
salimos de afganistán y salen las tropas
internacionales vencidas después de un
ataque terrible como el que se produjo
recientemente
cuál es el origen de este grupo
terrorista y de dónde además provienen
los recursos para mantenerse
en este grupo nace d
disidentes de los propios talibanes
personas e individuos vinculados a lo
que sería la parte más genuinamente
original del estado islámico que sería
irak y siria de ese conflicto y son
entre otros sujetos también del propio
afganistán disidentes de como digo de
los propios talibanes disidentes incluso
de lo que sería la al qaeda de
afganistán y están vinculados también no
lo olvidemos a una parte del espectro
talibán por mucho que ahora nos traten
de vender la idea de que son enemigos
del propio propio tolerantes no es así
parte del espectro de gobierno y de
responsabilidad dentro de los talibanes
está ocupado por la red haqqani en esta
situación esquizofrénica en la que nos
encontramos en estos momentos en los que
eeuu incluso ha negociado con los
programas para su salida de precipitada
de organizar la red haqqani es un grupo
terrorista es una red terrorista así
significada en las listas
internacionales y el propio ministro del
interior de los parianes es un sujeto
reclamado por los eeuu por los que se
ofrecen hasta 5 millones de dólares
estamos en una situación desconcertante
confusa y que ofrece un futuro bastante
bastante terrible